well hey you guys welcome back to
flickers of fear so if you guys remember
not too long ago I did this really big
massive Mega review of all five of the
VHS films that were then out uh it was
over on my scare Salon Channel which you
should go subscribe to that if you
haven't subscribed to that already but
that's where I did it I think it was
like an hour long or something so the
first five HS movies were mostly pretty
solid um other than viral which I didn't
really like that was like my least
favorite out of all of them um you know
and anybody that has watched any of my
reviews knows that I'm not really the
world's biggest fan of found footage
Horror in general although there were a
lot of exceptions to that uh rule I
there are a lot of them that I like but
I was intrigued enough by the whole VHS
concept and the you know of the series
to be pretty excited when shudder added
the newest uh in the series which which
is called VHS 85 to the lineup about a
week ago about a week before I'm
recording this um I actually quite
enjoyed the previous film in the series
which was VHS 94 but I was actually more
interested to see this one because it
was going to be you know set much more
early in time and would have more of
like an analog feel that would kind of
maybe transport me back to my young
teenage years because I was about 13
years old in 1985 so right off the bat I
will say that VHS 85 is now I think my
second favorite of the series like after
the first one which is still my favorite
and although a couple of the segments in
this were just sort of okay the bulk of
the movie really kind of just went for
it and made up for the slightly weaker
bits with just a whole bunch of Gore
really good storytelling and some kind
of like surprising twists and turns that
really kind of kept you on your toes so
just like the previous VHS movies uh you
got a couple of horror kind of Heavy
Hitters uh represented here in far as
far as directors get you got uh David
Brookner who did the ritual he did the
nigh house among other things uh and
Scott derkson who did The Exorcism of
Emily Rose Sinister the black phone uh
some I think he did one of the Doctor
Strange movies and you also have like a
couple of like upand cominging directors
uh Giga Guerrero who did um lenan era
and I think she directed some episodes
of The Purge series you know what I mean
like the TV series uh you got Natasha
kman who did lucky which was actually
like a pretty decent uh film and Mike P
Nelson who did the wrong turn movie from
2021 so this time out the wraparound
story is really kind of just more of a
segment in its own right which I kind of
feel like they were getting away from
the wraparounds by the time 94 rolled
around which you know honestly that's
fine with me I mean there's really only
so many ways you can set up hey somebody
found a cach of creepy old videotapes
and watches them for some reason so you
know just dispensing with the whole the
whole charade is like like I said that's
totally fine with me um you know you
shouldn't even really bother with it and
I'm glad that they didn't this time so I
I mean the movie seems a lot more
integrated that way anyway so David
brookner's you know sort of wraparound
is called total copy and it kind of
presents itself as like an inarch of
style made for TV documentary that's
actually been taped over here and there
like with the other segments which I
thought was like a really good idea so
this fake documentary is following This
research team at what I presume is a
fictional institution called steamer
University and they're studying this
presumably alien being I don't really
think they say like where it's from or
anything like that because it's like you
know when when the story starts they
already have it in custody um so but
this thing can replicate anything that
it sees like a lot like Invasion of the
Body Snatchers or the thing or something
like that so the scientists have named
this being Rory and have it held captive
in this kind of comfortable living room
type situ situation like behind this
oneway glass and they let it watch TV in
there in the hopes that it will kind of
like learn human culture and eventually
be able to communicate with them so
after the narrator of this documentary
hints that like some really horrifying
[__] is going to happen to these
scientists like further down the line uh
we actually cut to the first proper
segment of the movie which is called No
wake and it was directed by Mike P
Nelson now in this one there's this kind
of gang of young people like they're all
pretty likable you know none of them are
douchy or anything really so they're
kind of going on a trip and they just
blly like blow past some cons very
conspicuous like no trespassing signs
and they're going to spend the day water
skiing and picnicking like on this
really beautiful secluded Lake that
nobody else apparently knows about not
too long after starting the festivities
though um an unseen sniper on the shore
starts shooting at their boat and like
pretty much like picking them off one by
one now at first this would seem like it
was going to be a fairly straightforward
narrative and it actually did work very
well as that cuz it was really
terrifying like with the POV like you
know being shot out people like ducking
down in the boat and [__] like that but
I will note uh that things take a very
unexpected turn that I don't really want
to spoil because I was like oh uh all
right what the [__] going on now you
know what I mean um and also I love that
this segment eventually circles around
and connects with one of the later ones
um which was a link that I was I have to
say I was absolutely delighted by like
when I realized in the later segment
like what was happening that they were
tying it back I was like oh that was you
know I really really liked that I
thought it was cool so then we get
another bit of the documentary about
Rory and the scientists and all that and
then we get into the second full segment
which is uh called god of death which
was directed by GG salul Guerrero now
this one was like you know somewhat
compelling and like pretty bloody which
is cool but I feel like it went on a
little bit too long like before the big
reveal so I think this was one of the
two kind of lesser stories in the movie
I guess so in this one we're watching
like a Mexican it was like a morning
news program and they're kind of setting
up to go live so you have like the kind
of flirtacious famous like older anchor
wom her name is Luchia there's this kind
of hardworking affable cameraman named
Louise and this real perky like on the
street reporter chick named Gabriella
who I think is actually played by the
director herself uh a few minutes into
the broadcast however the building is
apparently struck by a huge
earthquake and Louise films pretty much
like the entire process of his rescue is
like him and the paramedics try to get
out of the building before it collapses
so they're like going through the
staircase and like the ceilings falling
in on them and [__] like that so all of
this is like harrowing enough cuz you
know even though you can say that Lis
wouldn't be filming that and even a
couple times they were just kind of like
why are you still filming like put that
camera down let's get the [__] out of
here you know what I mean so it does
have that little strange crul a little
bit but still it's like it's a pretty uh
it's a it's a pretty like
heart-wrenching kind of thing like
watching people trying to get out while
the building is like collapsing around
them but when the group gets down to
what I guess is like a sub basement or
something like that like trying to find
a way out of the rubble they find uh
let's just call this maybe like an
ancient evil that might have been
released by the earthquake or something
like that so as I said I mean this one
was fine but honestly I thought the
whole where escaping a collapsing
building storyline was like pretty
decent on its own and I have to say I
wasn't sure I was entirely on board when
things kind of went in the r overthe
toop kind of Supernatural kind of
Direction like toward the end um but you
know I thought it was cool that they
added that there was like that addition
of it it wasn't just that they were just
like out of the frying pan into the fire
type of thing but I thought it was a
little much or I thought it was like a
little over dramatic you know what I
mean um but you know your mileage may
vary of course uh I did notice that some
reviewers cuz I read a few reviews of
this after I watched it um did choose
this segment as their favorite one so
naturally this is all subjective like I
didn't love it but it was like pretty
good so then we get a bit more of the
documentary about Rory the
shape-shifting alien person dude being
whatever and then we segue into what I
think at least in my opinion is probably
like the most the least effective um you
know set segment of the movie so this
was directed by Natasha Carman and it's
called well it's called techn God but
it's just TK n o g d so you know what I
mean but I'm just going to call it
Technic so it starts out as like a
couple people
filming this unbearably pretentious
performance art piece like in this
little little club or something like
that and it's given by this woman who
tells the you know five people in the
audience or something which that tracks
um that humans have killed all their old
gods and have replaced them with a god
of technology so this like 1985 so you
know it's it's very like 1985 like
technology kind of speak so then she
uses this very early set of kind of like
VR goggles and gloves and she goes into
like she has this screen and she goes
into this wireframe you know virtual
world and she tries to like do all this
stuff to like supposedly contact this
technological God that supposedly lives
in this area so it's you know it's like
a one woman show type of thing um and
this Enterprise goes about as well as
you would expect um in other words it
goes not very well at all so again this
one was fine but it was a little bit
static because like a lot of it is just
set on this little stage with this one
woman like doing this stuff trying to
like you know doing this one woman show
where she's trying to you know bring
about this like techno God or whatever
and it so so it takes a while to get
going so I mean I've never been a big
fan of like performance art or you know
oneperson shows that aren't like
comedians or something like that so this
was a little bit of a SLO to sit through
I'm not going to lie um although I have
to say that if it was intended as like a
parody of stuff like that that was going
on in the ' 80s like these real
pretentious like poetry slams and stuff
like that then it's pretty spoton so I'm
going to give it like some props for
that um I will say the ending was pretty
great like pretty gory and uh the story
actually had kind of an amusing little
punchline I guess you would call it but
again I think it took like a just a
little bit too long to get there that's
all so then you have another bit with
Rory and his tentacle and uh you know as
the little documentary keep like keeps
on going and then we get into another
segment that was directed by Mike P
Nelson which is called Ambrosia and this
one ends up tying in with the earlier
segment that he directed no wake uh in a
really clever way I thought thought so
this one is actually set at this big
family party where the young woman who's
holding the camera whose name is Ruth is
being celebrated for something like we
don't find out what until later on we're
like what is it her birthday is she
graduating so it seems like something
like that so there's a few minutes of
like really realistic like family get
together Shenanigans as she's going
around going hey here's Uncle whoever
and here's my cousin Dave like the
weirdo and all you know what I mean and
they're all kind of like talking and
talking over each other so like I said
it's like very
realistic and then Ruth hands the camera
over to her geeky cousin which and I
kind of like this too because there's
kind of like a misdirect where she's
filming the geeky cousin who looks like
the stereotypical like 1985 like
computer nerd you know what I mean like
with this weird mullet and he's like all
kind of skinny like with the glasses and
stuff and he's like is that beta and
she's like yeah and he's like it's nice
and he's like can I film with it and so
and so you think because he's so weird
and creepy that that's going to factor
in but I kind of like that they there
was like a little bit of a misdirect
with that so both of them so then he's
filming Ruth and they both go outside
into the yard and then at this point
there's this little boy named Adam who
is maybe Ruth's younger brother I don't
really They Don't Really specify and I
guess it doesn't really matter he's just
like another kid at the party and he
starts shooting at her like with a water
pistol and she's like oh yeah oh no you
know what I mean like that and then
she's like hey where'd you get the water
pistol from that's pretty cool and he
says oh a lady that lady in the RV gave
it to me and so we look and she's like
what lady in RV what are you talking
about and then we look over and we see
the RV that belongs to the water skiing
kids from the first story from no wake
kind of Vanishing down the street so as
I said I'm not going to spoil what the
connection between them is or what's
going on at this party but I'm pretty I
think I can guarantee that you probably
will not be able to guess what it is I
mean maybe you will I don't really know
but I didn't that's for sure sure and so
I think this is like absolutely one of
those things where it's a lot better
going into it if you don't have any forn
knowledge of what's happening because
it's like a really good surprising twist
that I really in no way saw coming and I
thought it was like and when it was kind
of revealed I was like ah I was like
that was a really cool idea you know
what I mean so then we get some more
stuff with Rory and the researchers and
everything and then we get into the
final kind of proper segment probably my
favorite of the bunch uh this was the
one directed by Scott derkson it's
called dream kill so in this one we see
at the very beginning this woman getting
like horribly murdered and mutilated
from what you're led to presume is like
the POV of the killer who broke into her
house in the middle of the night and
she's on the phone cuz she can hear him
downstairs so she's like on the phone
with 911 like I can hear him he's coming
up the stairs and all this other kind of
stuff so it's really good like really
suspenseful um and you're led to believe
that the Killer is maybe filming the
entire encounter because we see
everything from his point of view but
when the cops show up a little while
later like the main detective guy whose
name is Detective Wayne he's pretty
disturbed by this whole scene because he
received a videotape of this exact crime
happened in this exact house in fact
like the same videotape that we thought
we watched at the beginning of the
segment but he received this 3 days ago
which of course is impossible because
the victim here has only been dead for a
couple of hours so then shortly after
that the cops get a second videotape and
that seemingly predicts another murder
that follows like a few days later so
Wayne decides he's going to stake out
like the public mailbox where they
determin that these videotapes have been
uh mailed from and he ends up picking up
this kind of softspoken goth kid named
Gunther and he's the one that's like
spotted dropping the package into the
box so they bring him in and he's kind
of stoic and everything like that and he
admits that he sent the tapes naturally
this would lead the cops to assume that
this kid is the killer uh let's just say
that the truth is a lot more bizarre
than anything you might have anticipated
so yeah this segment was great it was
really gruesome it was really violent um
it had a really great premise like a lot
of a great setup like a lot of great
suspense where you were just kind of
like it it just kept you guessing the
entire time like what in on Earth is
like going on this whole time and it was
really good and like the analog look at
the shots in in this uh segment in
particular like really enhanced the
horror of this one and I think it made
good use of like switching between VHS
tape kind of interspersed with different
types of CCTV footage and things like
that like to keep it from getting too sy
so I thought that was like a good choice
as well so after dream kill is over then
the movie kind of reverts back to the
Quasi wraparound thing which kind of
shows the end of the documentary that
explains what happened with the
scientists that were studying Rory so
this was also like a pretty solid ending
um very very gory which I thought was
cool and it wraps up with like a little
kind of visual joke that that actually
kind of made me laugh out loud like when
I saw it I was like yeah okay that was
pretty funny so yeah I mean all in all I
thought VHS 85 was just a hell of a lot
of fun uh it's easily my second favorite
like I said of the you know now Six film
series it had a very consistent look
it's all set in the same year and it was
all like very analog looking and it had
a consistent tone too um all of the
segments were more or less serious there
wasn't really much comedy in them and I
think that that was like a big plus
because I'm kind of not I know that a
lot of Anthology movies like not all of
them obviously but a lot of Anthology
movies horror anthologies seem to feel
like oh well we need one segment that's
kind of funny or that's like a horror
comedy and I'm like no you don't really
need that I think it like works better
if all of the stories have the same uh
tone to them like you know that are
thematically Rel you know kind of the
same like I think that flows better so
all of these were kind of like they had
like little funny moments in them but
none of them were like overly comedic
because I do kind of feel like some of
the other VHS movies would have like
scary one scary one scary when oh goofy
funny one and then scary one you know
what I mean so this didn't really have
that so I was glad that uh that it had
that and I'm going to say like all the
stories here um were definitely worth
watching and I'm going like even though
god of death and techn God weren't you
know as awesome as the other ones um the
remaining three stories and the
wraparound I kind of feel like they more
than carried the weight of the whole
film so they could kind of make up for
just these two being like ah those were
just okay you know what I mean cuz the
other ones was so good so I just feel
like this was a really entertaining like
return to form for the series like I
said I thought it was even better than
'94 and it just goes to show that I
guess there's still some life in this uh
premise yet and honestly I just read an
article yesterday that said that this uh
premiere on shutter had been so
successful like even more successful
than '94 which was at that time that
that came out the most successful but
now this one is um that they've already
green lit a seventh film which I think
is going to be more sci-fi oriented it's
going to be the same format but it's
going to be sci-fi which I'm not as
jazzed about cuz I'm not as into sci-fi
as I am into horror but I will probably
still watch it anyway but yeah if you
have shudder you can probably get this
on Amazon Prime too as well but I saw it
on shudder and that's where it premiered
um and you like found footage you like
the VHS series I definitely think this
is one of the best entries in the series
for sure so that will do it for this
flickers of fear hope you guys enjoyed
remember please like share subscribe
comment all of that kind of stuff and I
will see you guys again on the next one
bye me